on poursuit cette édition spéciale de
leur vie économique est consacré
vraiment à répondre à vos questions avec
l'avocate marianne plamondon et le
fiscaliste luc godbout
on y voit tout de suite avec une autre
question un employé qui ne veut pas
rentrer au travail et il dans son droit
de le faire marianne que le monde on met
ça a été la question toute la semaine la
simple peur n'est pas suffisant pour ne
pas se présenter au travail la santé
publique a décidé de maintenir les
milieux de travail de maintenir les
opérations des employeurs donc dans ce
cadre là à moins d'avoir une raison
justifiée
donc où on a un risque imminent pour sa
santé sécurité
avec évidemment des éléments concernant
sa santé qui fait en sorte qu'on était à
risque si on se présente dans le milieu
de travail
on doit se présenter au travail c'est
important quand même que notre économie
continue à marcher
et si les employeurs continuent à opérer
il faut que les employées et employés se
présente je sais que plusieurs
employeurs ont été pris avec des gros
taux d'absentéisme anyway par le travail
oui mais en même temps certaines usines
toutes les usines de production c'est
pas possible il faut être sur la ligne
de production
ok ben peut-être que la prochaine
situation peut s'appliquer ici je
travaille dans un centre d'appels pour
la ramq une assurance maladie je suis
très inquiète
nous sommes tous assis près 1 de l'autre
séparés par des paravents que doit faire
mon employeur mais l'obligation de
l'employeur c'est de s'assurer de la
santé sécurité au travail de ses
employés et les employeurs qui encore à
ce jour n'ont pas pris de mesures pour
préventive pour s'assurer de porcs qui
est pas de propagation du virus
hoarau sein de l'organisation ben là et
commence à être pas mal en retard il
faut qu'ils aient des mesures où on
oblige le lavage des mains on oblige de
désinfecter un milieu de travail de
façon fréquente on assure que les gens
soient à une distance de deux mètres
même sur les lignes de production on
essaie de réorganiser le travail pour
respecter ces mesures là évidemment un
empereur qu'il fait pas va s'exposer à
des plaines des employés auprès de la
csst
je suis étudiante et mère de deux
enfants 2 et 7 h des prêts et bourses et
je travaille pendant mes cours pour
joindre les deux bouts
maintenant que les garderies sont fermés
et ce que je suis éligible pour les deux
autres plein pour aider les familles
sachant que je ne suis pas éligible pour
le chômage le goût
ben ici si la personne n'est pas
admissible à l'assurance emploi et mais
qu'elle doit rester à la maison pour
s'occuper de jeunes enfants elle va est
admissible à la location de soins
d'urgence du gouvernement fédéral donc
ça c'est déjà une bonne nouvelle
et pour le reste je rappelle encore une
fois les bonifications allocation
canadienne pour enfants
que dit pépé et je présume si la
personne est étudiant qu'elle se
qualifie à ces deux mesures la de plein
droit et donc ça voudrait dire pour une
famille monoparentale encore une fois
près de 1500 $ qui va rentrer dans les
prochaines semaines puisqu'on parle des
étudiants ça s'applique sans doute pas
elle directement parce qu'elle est
encore sur les bancs d'école mais le
gouvernement fédéral est il le
gouvernement du québec ont fait des
annonces concernant des prêts étudiants
du côté d'ottawa on a dit qu'on suspende
est des intérêts payables sur les prêts
étudiants
et du côté de québec on est allé plus
loin on a dit qu'on suspend des
déremboursements sur les prêts étudiants
alors vous a confirmé les étudiants en
général c'est confirmé le cleee
remboursement suspendu au québec a été
annoncée à la craie d'aujourd'hui
dernière oui je les ratés c'est là donc
les remboursements de prêts étudiants
suspendus pendant quoi six mois au
québec
j'ai malheureusement pas noté le temps
mais j'ai noté qu'il avait été annoncée
aujourd'hui donc oui ça doit être pour
les six prochains mois mais sinon pour
quelques temps du port de québec il ya
plus de remboursement iront voir
ferrandes on va reprendre alerte plus
tard ça veut dire avec le même niveau
d'endettement sais pas c'est le
gouvernement du québec qui va payer les
intérêts pendant la période où il n'y a
pas de remboursement les travailleurs de
l'hôtellerie seront ils indemnisés temps
partiel aussi marianne le monde ont de
même façon que tous les autres
travailleurs là donc si on est mise à
pied je sais que plusieurs hôtels
procéder à des mises à pied cette
semaine
compte tenu de l'absence d' occupation
alors ils vont pouvoir tombes lit sur
l'assurance emploi si l'on cumule il le
fait sans heurts dans les 52 dernières
semaines mais autrement ils peuvent eux
est éligible aux autres programmes on a
vu la location le des soins d'urgence et
chez terreur autre question j'aimerais
savoir s'il ya de quoi pour les
personnes à faible revenu et chivu et
qui ont un prêt personnel à payer le
godbout il n'y a pas rien directement
mais il ya quand même quelque chose
indirectement dans la mesure où le
gouvernement fédéral a pris entente avec
les banques et en leur demandant d'être
accommodante alors c'est vrai pour les
prêts hypothécaires mais c'est vrai pour
les prêts personnels également donc en
code de doughty vous avez un bris dans
vos revenus que vous êtes à faible
revenu et que vous avez besoin de
repousser un copain contactez votre
institution financière c'est la
meilleure gouasmi autre question je suis
un travailleur autonome je travaille
avec hubert à temps plein avec la
fermeture de l'école doit garder mes
enfants la maison est ce que j'ai droit
au soutien du gouvernement fédéral ou
provincial mais rien de tout le monde on
alors ils ont accès au programme
d'allocation de soins d'urgence les
travailleurs autonomes sont inclus dans
ce programme leur jeu rappelle on parle
de jusqu'à 900 $ pour deux semaines
qui va pouvoir s'échelonner sur quinze
semaines si jamais ils ne sont pas
éligibles dans ce programme là ils vont
pouvoir se rabattre sur celui le
programme provincial des deux
travailleurs celui ci aussi inclus les
travailleurs autonomes
rappelons également leur part des
obligations en matière d'acomptes
provisionnels pour les travailleurs
autonomes autonome jusqu'au 31 ou 2020
qui va leur permettre aussi de souffle
il nous sommes de vrais petits
entrepreneurs qui ont ouvert leur
commerce avec leurs économies je me
demandait de quelle façon concrètement
cette mesure peut nous aider je pense
qu'on parle de la mesure de monsieur
fatigué benoît qui est annoncé hier les
prêts et comment procéder le good book
alors si on parle de mesures faites ce
binz qu'il faut bien comprendre ce
programme d'action concerté temporaire
ou les entreprises
le ministe physique est bonne le bien
dit on peut pas sauver l'ensemble des
entreprises c'est un fonds d'urgence
pour aide aux liquidités des entreprises
si l'entreprise allait bien avant les
événements
donc c'est pas une entreprise qui était
non rentables avant les événements donc
l'entreprise allait bien et que son
problème de liquidités est causée par la
crise du coroner virus dans ce cas là
elle pourra faire une demande
le montant minimal de la rd 50 mille
dollars sous forme de paix
et lorsqu'il faut bien comprendre
peut-être le seul reproche là mais
cinquante mille dollars pour certaines
petites petites petites entreprises
c'est peut-être trop comme revendre
alors là c'est peut-être le seul
reproche mais sinon c'est l'idée c'est
d'aller chercher jusqu'à st
minimum de 50 mètres donc et plus mais
dispute gabbana prévu 2.5 milliards
dans ce contexte là aux besoins soit 60
de plus les entreprises ont besoin
davantage de liquidités pour terminer
quels sont les obligations des télés de
travailleurs qui sont nombreux marianne
plamondon
alors ils ont les mêmes obligations que
s'il était au travail ils ont une
obligation de loyauté donc c'est
important pour les télétravailleurs
d'être honnête avec leur emploi s'ils
sont pas capables de faire leur tâche
faut se rappeler aussi qu'ils ont
l'obligation de maintenir la
confidentialité des données de
l'employeur même s'ils sont à la maison
donc soyez vigilants sur les papiers qui
traînent sur le bureau également assurer
leur santé sécurité au travail donc
s'assurer d'être dans un lieu
sécuritaire mais chose certaine les
employant vont s'attendre à la même
productivité même si les gens sont à la
maison et donc les employés les
employeurs doivent se parler communiquer
leurs attentes mutuelles de façon à
s'assurer que ça fonctionne correctement
mais ce n'est pas simple de vérifier ça
quand même
mais le mieux c'est la communication est
d'avoir la meilleure façon c'est
d'évaluer par la performance sur des
résultats des objectifs fixés
marion tout le monde on c'était limpide
le godbout également merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
cleese et pourquoi comment va-t-on se
sortir de cette crise je vous propose
une discussion avec clément gignac
l'économiste et vincent delisle de
stratège
dans le cadre de questions d'intérêt
notre balade au économique sur
l'application audio des réponses à vos
questions
samedi 17h30 heure de l'est dimanche
21h30 heure de l'est des réponses à vos
questions édition spéciale donc c'est en
fin de semaine sur